well we're joined by Paul Goldsmith
author of How to Lose a referendum the
definitive story of why the UK voted for
brexit good morning good morning when
there is a possibility in all of this
isn't that we may look back in 50 100
years and see this is the golden era of
British politics well certainly that's
what's happening at the school I teach
at kids coming into my office teachers
coming into my office to ask what's
going on but I think how historians view
this era could probably be boiled down
into three areas one I think they'll
condemn David Cameron at - I think they
might look back as this ere is the time
and the disconnect between what voters
wanted and needed grew between what they
wanted a needed and what political
parties could provide through policies
but three depending on how this crisis
is resolved it could be the time when
the people lost faith in politics
ability to resolve conflicts they do say
history repeats itself is there anything
in the past that we can equate to what
is happening now anything any precedent
at all well it's it's interesting
because Suez which was mentioned by Kate
in her piece Suez was a failure of
leadership the cabinet didn't even know
Suez was happening because Anthony Eden
shredded any notes from the meetings
that he had but the political parties
were still serving the interests of the
voters labour represented the working
class conservatives represented I
suppose the ruling class and they were
responding very well to these people who
believed in them that's not necessarily
happening now so in that sense then what
do you see as the disconnect is is the
disconnect that politicians aren't
delivering on the referendum or is it
that the country because the countries
the country is split still and the
politicians seem to be split still I
mean the splits are astonishing the
political parties are bursting at the
seams with almost irreconcilable
factions and one thing that could happen
our actual splits one to the right and
perhaps some labour towards the center
maybe we'll have more coalition's but I
think the referendum itself was the
result of the disconnect that happened
starting in about 1979 with what
happened to the many communities around
the country who were sort of abandoned
when the mines were closed but also in
2000 globalization immigration people's
worries globalization career
winners and it creates losers but the
losers were sort of told you're lazy
racist bigots and we're not interested
in you and then extremists sort of
stepped into the breach and presented
well we've got an answer let's have this
referendum but wait I mean it's not a
fair analysis in the sense that there
are a lot of political historians that
look back at you know the facture
government from 79 onwards and say
although yep hugely unpopular both
through a lot of the sort of economic
actions that were taken but now look
back at that with you with the with with
the sort of the the benefit of hindsight
and say this actually put the country
back on the road to economic success and
that's interesting because I think one
of the crises that was missed out in the
piece you just showed was the winter of
discontent in 1978 we were called the
sick man of Europe we were going to the
International Monetary Fund for a loan
we had garbage piling up on the streets
of Leicester Square and things like that
Margaret Thatcher though had a large
majority she knew what she wanted to do
she was able to deliver it whether we
like it or not David Cameron however if
I said to you eight years ago someone's
going to come along call a referendum
with no intention of delivering one of
the results didn't prepare for ruining
the results resigned when that result
happened leaving a government to deliver
a policy that didn't believe in with
incomplete instruction from the
electorate you might have said what kind
of Banana Republic are we in and when
historians judged Theresa May they they
need to consider the poison chalice she
was handed but Theresa May with her type
when she lost a majority in 2017 she
certainly played a bad hand badly are we
seeing a redefining of politics we mean
the cusp of that we're going to see new
parties emerging I think so I think that
the the people on the right of
conservative party are not really
conservative they're saying there's
nothing to lose from there's nothing to
be afraid of with no deal they're saying
let's break this and see what happens
that's not necessarily conservative
maybe they could be part of a new clip a
new UK people in the Labor Party on the
Blair right wing they're more centrist
they believe in accommodating capitalism
maybe they'd be better off in a centrist
party but then people have to get used
to coalition's running the country then
because under our current electoral
system it favors the big parties a lot
more than a lot of little ones so we
could have politics redefined yes
well I'll tell you what one thing we can
agree on Paul is that we're gonna look
back at this with a lot of interest
that's for sure good to talk to this
morning thank you very much indeed